is another repeat speaker
has three children age seven four and
one
and she still beats all of them I need
to finish that sentence otherwise that's
bad
she still beats all the Mario Kart
please welcome major Max
today I will be talking about building
large shiny apps some techniques that I
use while working in the army
to start with personal introduction I am
an army officer I've been in the Army
for 13 years I started
as an engineer kind of like dusty over
there
um our job as Engineers is to both break
things and build things I don't know how
that works but it it works somehow and
uh after that I changed my career field
to operations research systems analyst I
see some head nods I know there are a
few of us out out there and um my first
job well I studied operations research
at George Mason University down the road
and then my first job was at Center for
Army analysis and we've heard that one a
couple times too what CAA is is the lead
analytical Agency for specifically for
headquarters Department of the army and
CAA focuses primarily on the Strategic
realm so that highest conceptual realm
of military operations sustainment
planning Etc
the
after that I moved to Fort Eustis near
Williamsburg where I work now at Future
concept Center and what FCC is is we
conceive of and develop the future
Concepts and capabilities for the Army
in The Joint Force so we're talking
Concepts and capabilities from 23 year
2030 2040 and what I mean by concept I'm
talking technology organizational
structure maybe new Personnel
Specialties maybe we'll we'll conceive
of a data scientist in the year 2030 as
a as a military occupational specialty
uh that's the sort of stuff we do
so as a data scientist is that's my job
title right now what do I do I
kind of Do It All We and and the other
horses can probably relate to this we do
data science data analysis data
engineering data
um we troubleshoot Excel we automate
processes we take notes when needed we
basically do whatever our organization
needs us to do to get data to inform
decisions and what that means is that we
develop breadth but not necessarily a
lot of depth in one one specific data
oriented career field
um we use r a lot R in our studio R is
definitely the most accessible of the
powerful data science tools uh given all
of our the security restrictions in the
dod Network
um we I'll give you some examples of
what we do so we do big mathematical
models uh coded sir model we use machine
learning algorithms uh did linear linear
programming like we mentioned yesterday
uh for example a network flow linear
program for Logistics war game so more
than just NFL
modeling and uh and then a lot of bit
process automation organizations come to
us we have this repetitive process
please help us and another one that I'm
working on right now is designing a
database schema for to help individual
uh an organization
um organize their data structure their
data and then we build a front end for
them
everything that I just listed almost
everything I just listed we we like to
build a shiny app as a means to deliver
the the code so that the customer
doesn't have to look at code instead
they can just plug some inputs in Click
some buttons
they get their output
um
we also deploy it on our RS connect we
usually use a cloud environment we have
a few different Cloud environments that
we use in in the Army and uh but as far
as the the actual product that we hand
them it's it's a lot of times it's shiny
if I were to show you an army app that
I've made or that my teams have made uh
it would bore you to tears and I'd
probably get in trouble so I'm not going
to do that to either of us instead I
have my own personal meal planner shiny
app uh you're welcome to look at it it
is on the shiny i o i don't pay them so
I don't know maybe I'll break it either
way I'll be able to look at it still
because
it is uh I'm running it locally
so uh before I pull it up
I have three children planning meals is
a bit of a headache
um two working parents you all get yada
yada yada you all get it uh when you're
planning meals it uh is a bit of a
process and so like any good coder I
spent countless hours automating a
process that would otherwise take me 10
minutes to do
um
so here's what I did I I have a shiny
dashboard here and I uh have three pages
choose meals shopping list and edit meal
data on this first page I can input my
meals for breakfast on Monday I'm going
to have chia seed pudding sounds boring
on uh Tuesday I'll have fajitas for
lunch Thursday I'll have uh vegetables
um
then I can choose my Staples uh almond
milk and bananas and I go to my shopping
list and I generate my shopping list
haven't decided what I want to do with
this for now it's a work in progress but
you get the idea the the techniques oh
and one more thing um if I want to edit
the meal data I can do that here what
we're looking at here is an R Hands-On
table if you haven't used it it's a
pretty handy feature or a pretty handy
package I should say and it allow it
gives you a fully editable table which
obviously we would use with discretion
because we oftentimes don't want to give
our users the option to fully edit a
table but um but I want to be able to do
it and you can structure it slightly
something you cannot do in an editable
data table in shiny is a drop down box
you see this
um I made a drop down box in this row of
data so it's pretty handy
and also has the Excel you use uh user
experience which is kind of nice okay
so we have this example
the techniques that I use here that I
also use in in building large shiny apps
in the Army are three there are three of
them the first is shiny modules the
second is reactive functions and the
third is something uh it is
generating UI and mass by groups of UI
using pers map functions that's a lot
I'll get there
so shiny modules first of all what is a
shiny module a shiny module is a pair of
functions a UI function and a server
function
they're slightly unique from other
functions now all of the benefits of
functions that Mark went over yesterday
and the benefits of functions that we
are already aware of apply to shiny
modules one thing I will emphasize is
that shiny modules
oh and modularizing your script
into multiple scripts uh specifically is
more conducive to devops if you try to
merge use git to merge one single long
script it's gonna probably no it's a
real headache when you have multiple
people working on one script got a lot
of merge conflicts if you have multiple
scripts then I work on module one
um
Michaela you work on module two Dusty
module three then Robert you just
checked Dusty's work because
I don't know got a lot of typos in that
one
but you get the idea
um great for distributed teams working
on something
um the other thing about modules is they
create a namespace this is what makes
sets them apart from just regular old
functions and namespace is important
because if you have a shiny app with and
multiple inputs have the same name or
multiple outputs have the same name
you're going to have problems at best
you will get an error at worst you will
not get an error and you'll just get
some really funky results
um so let's look at how I like to
structure a shiny app or I'm using a
shiny dashboard here so the first thing
I do and this is when you're in our
studio you open up your new shiny web
app you select single file and you have
your app.r you delete the sample app
that they give you and then I would copy
my shell in here and start working from
here and changing the names that I want
so first thing I do is I Source my
Global script with all my functions and
then I Source my individual modules I
have one module per script that's just
my personal preference I Define my
header my sidebar that's all pretty
standard stuff and then I go down to my
body notice I have tab items which gives
me the pages on the shiny dashboard on
the left hand side and then I have my
meal Staples I have my three UI
functions
if I go down further into the server
script I have my three server
functions now just because a server and
a UI happen to be in the same module
script does not mean that those are a
linked pair what actually links them and
gets them to talk to each other in the
app is the ID argument so let's look at
edit data server this first server right
here ID equals edit data tab if I go to
up here edit data UI the ID equals edit
data tab they match therefore this UI
function and server will talk to each
other and they will not talk to any
other module no other crosstalk
okay so that's the what I call the
parent app and then the module itself
uh what I would do with the module is
what I actually do is I I have a shell
an empty shell that I just copy and
paste every time I want to start a new
module because there's a specific syntax
that you got to follow specifically you
have you have to the first thing you do
in either one of each one of the
functions is you define your name space
that's what I'm doing here on line three
and then the other thing I'll highlight
in the UI function is that you can have
multiple individual pieces of UI in your
UI function but you do have to wrap them
in uh some container a div container or
a tag list
um so that it it comes out of the
function as one H one component rather
than lots of individual components okay
and then in the server function notice
the syntax here module server and then
you you define your ID there that that
defines your namespace
okay the next thing I want to talk about
reactive functions I'm going to
crowdsource something
uh
a is I explain what reactive functions
are and B is I assume you know what
reactive functions are and I show you my
personal rules of thumb on how I
Implement them so A's
raise your hand
got a couple of these
oh okay
good I wasn't expecting that
okay
all right so
I ignore reactive Val that function is
useless to me
um
I stick with reactive values I like how
it gives me a list uh it looks more like
a list and I can reassign it just like
it was a list I don't have to worry
about the weird parentheses thing even
though it seems like an object to me
that that part just confuses me so I use
reactive values in this case I'm
assigning ingredients as one reactive
value and Stables as another reactive
value notice I'm just reading in files
that's how I use reactive values is when
I just want to do one simple thing read
in a table that's the initial value for
these items
and then I use the reactive expression
so I use reactive Expressions anytime I
want to perform some calculation and
that calculation is going to remain the
same for this particular object so every
time I call ingredients category I want
to perform the same calculation and that
calculation includes some other reactive
value some existing reactive value or an
input so that's when I use reactive
Expressions that's this function right
here
um
and then I Define my output notice this
output is not nested in some reactive
function uh it's generally speaking it's
best to make sure your output stands
alone and I certainly use reactive
values to Define what the output is for
instance I'm using my I'm building my R
Hands-On table and I'm using a reactive
value here V dollar sign ingredients and
then next one down I say okay I want to
make the category column editable and I
want to make it a drop down box Source
the options for the drop down box from
my reactive value category and in this
case because it's a reactive Express
category is a reactive expression
because I use that reactive expression
function up here I have to say category
open close parentheses if I don't then
it'll give me an error saying something
like expecting a vector but it's
actually a reactive expression something
to that effect you got you're missing
parentheses or you've missed misnamed
your your reactive value there
and then I use event reactive event
reactive and observe event are very
similar what distinguishes them is it
event reactive ends up giving you an
object use event reactive when you want
to make a calculation that ends in some
reactive object that you want to use
later on in your script
observe event use this uses the same
syntax basically but
you don't assign it to an object we use
observe event when we want to
perform some side action write to a
database write to CSV we don't actually
want a value out of that operation
okay so that's that's kind of how I use
those and I think I captured all of the
the good ones left out reactive bowel
but um okay
the last thing I want to cover is
generate oh I got some time too okay
good
generating UI in Mass with per
so let's I'm going to explain this one
by visual example and then I probably
won't have time to go line by line
through the code but I will give you
this presentation afterwards so if
you're interested in that uh you can
certainly look at that see how I code
this and then uh talk to me afterwards
of course
okay
so
you see a lot of drop down boxes here
I did not code each one of those
individually if I did it would be awful
um instead I have a function that gives
me one single drop down box
and that function takes in arguments
that will Define the parameters for that
drop down box label options selected
that sort of thing and
I use per to apply that I use per to
apply a set of arguments not just one
single set of arguments but a vector or
a vector or a list or a data frame of
arguments to that function
and those arguments are reactive
so
kind of sidestepping here what is what
is really common and normal in what we
all do in shiny is we make a drop down
box and we make the up the options
reactive but what I'm describing is
something slightly different this does
that what I'm describing is that the UI
itself is reactive so if I
check Saturday because I want to plan
for Saturday too it will give me an
entire new column which is still the
same function being just repeated again
and again and I have another function on
the back end that parse or reads those
inputs it interprets those inputs in
series and then collapses them into a
data frame it's all using per the map
function and the pmap function because a
lot of them require a lot of arguments
and because I have time I will show you
some of the code but it is a little
dense
um so first thing I do is I Define my
function I'll kind of go over the whole
thing first first thing I do is I Define
my function to generate the check check
boxes in this case this is what the
example is giving me
um you can see that it's just saying
give me a out of this function I want
one column and in that column I want a
checkbox group input it's a group of
check boxes and then I uh have the the
the arguments are a data frame so it's
going to give I want to feed a table
into this then I have my Staples table
that has all the Staples collapsed into
one table with a category column and an
item column and I group split that table
by category so now I have a list with
tables and each table is for a unique
category and then with the map function
I feed each that list of tables into my
function and the output is
of something like five or six that could
change depending on what Staples is at
the time but five right now five or six
Columns of checkbox groups
so it's pretty handy
um I would when I would I would
recommend using this method when you
have to make
um several pieces of UI all of which
follow a very similar parameter pattern
but if you have UI that every single one
of them is very unique don't bother
um I would and and don't confuse this
with shiny modules when I use shiny
modules is for
um you when when I have lots of UI and
lots of code I I wouldn't necessarily
this it what I'm describing here with
the per function is when I have a
smaller piece of UI that I want to use
over and over and over and over again
um I know that was a lot I'm happy to
continue the discussion and my primary
reference is mastering shiny
specifically for the reactive functions
he has a great chapter on that and the
shiny modules
um and then in conclusion I I really
appreciate uh all all of your attention
and I uh I really enjoy speaking so I
look forward to uh speaking next year
okay
thank you
and this is the the presentation if you
care to look I published it thanks to
someone one of the speakers yesterday I
can't remember I published it on uh
quarto Pub so it's there and I'll look
at it
and that concludes my presentation